just because an actor is contracted to
film a movie if that doesn't mean
they're forced to do every scene in the
original script from nudes to feud's
here's a look at movie scenes that
actors refused to film a super spy eggsy
in the Kingsmen series Taron Egerton a
sky rocketed from a relative unknown to
an in-demand the leading man despite his
worldwide success a steamy scene with
poppy delle Vigne in the second
installment of the spy franchise
Kingsman the Golden Circle was a little
too hot for him to handle in the scene a
Jetsons egg seized and the pressure to
place a tracking device inside the
Levine's clora during an intimate moment
however Edgerton was incredibly
uncomfortable with the plan seen a
relationship instead the Levine's
real-life husband the played eggsy's
hand in the shots Edgerton himself
seemed relieved later saying he saved
the world back in 2008 for Christmas
cysts are like the best idea since
Christmas tree cakes and rum spied
eggnog put America's Sweetheart Reese
Witherspoon and funny man Vince Vaughn
together as a couple that's forced to
spend Christmas with their disapproving
divorced relatives and holiday chaos
ensues
however the reviews were abysmal with
many critics punting the lack of
chemistry between the leads as it turns
out it was a Christmas miracle the film
got finished at all since Weatherspoon
and Vaughn couldn't stand each other the
two were complete opposites from the
beginning she arrived bright and early
to the sets he would wander in looking
like he partied at night before she
wanted to rehearse and block scenes he
wanted to ad-lib their relationship
through so cold that Reese is reported
to have refused a bedroom scene with
Vaughn which was ultimately scrapped
from the finished film it sounds like
there could have been a better way for
the two co-stars to get along that's not
gonna bring when he gets to hurting
inside and can't use his emotion words
who takes two streak if you've ever seen
Borat Bruno or basically any of Sacha
Baron Cohen's work you know the dude has
zero issues with filming in his birthday
suits so it's no surprise that he
expects the same nonchalance about
nudity from his co-stars
however one of his famous female scene
partners flat-out refused to go nude
despite Cohen's badgering
rebel Wilson is known for her
anything goes brand of humor however she
refuses to go nude and it is written
into a contract that a close stay on in
2016 sub brothers Grimsby Wilson played
the girlfriend of Coen screw up turned
spy character and one scene code for
full frontal nudity against her wishes
Wilson won the battle not that many
people would know the brothers Grimsby
and an atrocious 25 million dollar total
at the worldwide box office or less than
what Borah
made in one weekend Amber Heard has gone
nude on film before but when it came
time to go topless for 2018 s London
Fields she flat-out refused and
consequently was sued by producers for
10 million dollars
based on a novel of the same name at the
film stars herd as Nicholas 6 a
clairvoyant femme fatale who predicts
she'll be murdered by one of her three
lovers given both the script and the
novel it was based on contained nude
scenes producers argued that Hurd was
well aware should be asked to go nude
producers argued that her and
willingness to strip for the film
severely disrupted their production and
that she tried to pull the film from the
Toronto International Film Festival
lineup in 2015 the production company
Nicolas six Limited sued her for 10
million dollars or about 40 times what
London Fields eventually made at the
domestic box office when it was finally
released in 2018 it's two hundred and
fifty thousand dollar take makes it one
of the biggest bombs in history the 1994
romantic comedy I love trouble is
remembered these days for inspiring one
of the most notorious co-star feuds ever
Julia Roberts and Nick Nolte star is
dueling Chicago reporters chasing the
same scoop murder mayhem and romance
ensue and while the filmmakers were
hoping for a Tracy Hepburn spark what
they got was an ulti Roberts dumpster
fire
the Petersons self-defense classes a
muster a woman of the night supposedly
roberts disliked Nolte's loutish
machismo so much that she would insult
him on set
Nolte grew so tired of this that it act
up just to spite her it got so bad the
two refused to film their scenes
together and acted with stand-ins
instead Roberts and Nolte played nice
drawing promotion but proving that time
does not heal all wounds they continued
to hold a grudge years later in 2003
Roberts called Nolte a disgusting human
being
Nolte responded it's not nice to call
someone disgusting but she's not a nice
person everyone knows that Nick Nolte
has been nominated for an Academy Award
three times or Julia Roberts won one for
two thousand seven Brokovich sounds like
both of them deserve an Oscar for even
briefly pretending to like each other
Jim Caviezel became a household name if
not a Hollywood a-lister for his role as
Jesus Christ in Mel Gibson's 2003
passion project The Passion of the
Christ
before going biblical Caviezel was well
on his way to being the next big
blockbuster heartthrob with parts and
frequency the Count of Monte Cristo and
Angel Eyes it was in the latter two that
the devout Catholics earned himself a
reputation for refusing explicit sex
scenes Tinseltown is a tough place for
chastity and Caviezel raised eyebrows
when he would only do a love scene with
Jennifer Lopez and Angel Eyes if she
kept her clothes on he likewise refused
to film a scene with his Monte Cristo
co-star that merida men's 'ok unless she
puts something between them your Vizslas
argued that his commitment to staying
clothed is out of respect for his wife
and his Catholic faith if it is
embarrassing the people on sets if they
think you're a wimp that you're an
embarrassment to talking this way well
I'd rather be embarrassed before the
whole country than before God Will Smith
was riding high in the early 1990s with
a successful hip hop career and an even
more successful TV show The Fresh Prince
of bel-air before discovering his
penchant for making broadly appealing
blockbuster movies Smith sought to
establish himself as a serious actor
right out of the gate with 1993 to six
degrees of separation based on the play
of the same name the movie has a dense
character driven plots and complicated
themes and while Smith was willing to
take a risk a script called for
something he refused to do and
film Smith's gay character is required
to share a passionate kiss with his male
co-star Anthony Michael Hall Smith
wasn't comfortable with this and sought
advice from Denzel Washington who
supposedly told him not to kiss a man on
camera so that's precisely what Smith
that didn't do a shot was filmed from
behind allowing Smith to fake air in the
horror spoof sequel scary movie 5
Lindsay Lohan was supposed to kiss
Charlie Sheen three times in their
bedroom scene however Lohan refused to
lock lips have she now - fear of germs
or worse from his hard-partying past
both stars had already signed releases a
saying that it didn't have cold sores
but even with contractual assurances
Lohan still refused to smooch while
filmmakers try to use a body double they
ultimately just dropped most of the
kissing from the scene entirely sorry
it's my sobriety monitor truly I'm
scared
there's nothing to be afraid of although
the pair would eventually lock lips
years later on an episode of Sheen's
anger management TV show if you think of
Wayne's World you probably think of
Wayne Garth and the gang
head-banging and lip-syncing - Queen's
Bohemian Rhapsody writes according to
Myers it almost wasn't Queen's
masterpiece say Santo but a Guns and
Roses tune courtesy of director Penelope
Spheeris she believed that a modern day
rock hit would fit the bill better than
Queen and Myers was like nah fortunately
he stuck to his guns and refused to film
the scene unless it was Bohemian
Rhapsody
despite being his first movie Maya's got
his way saving the now iconic scene and
propelling Bohemian Rhapsody back up to
the top 40 list for the first time in
years check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more loop of videos
about your favorite stuff are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]